[Musique]
je vais vous dire que nous avons encore
notre destin entre nos mains
grâce à l'une des couvertures vaccinales
les plus fortes au monde grâce aux
gestes barrières grâce au pass
sanitaires deux hélicoptères survolent
le détroit suite à l'appel d'un pêcheur
au fur et à mesure des patrouilles
plusieurs corps sont retrouvés des
femmes une petite fille au moins 27
migrants sont morts en tentant la
traversée je suis choqué révolté et
profondément attristés par les pertes de
ces vies en mer jeudi à nos partenaires
de l'autre côté de la manche le temps
est venu d'avancer de travailler
ensemble et de tout faire pour briser
ces réseaux meurtrier je pense qu'il
n'est pas sur ce sujet suffisamment
impliqué il ya de mon point de vue un
devoir de mobilisation du royaume uni
dans cette affaire il faut pouvoir les
convaincre de cela et ces trafiquants il
joue de nos frontières il joue
malheureusement nos différences de
législation et jouent parfois un peu
aussi de notre manque de coopération
dans ce domaine pour lutter contre les
passeurs j'ai aucune sympathie pour les
pacers m'enfin là on parle du moyen on
ne parle pas des raisons pour lesquelles
des gens risquent leur vie sur la manche
ou en méditerranée et c'est aussi
l'attractivité la grande bretagne qui
est en cause notamment de son marché du
travail puisque chacun sait qu'il ya un
million plus d'un million un million
deux cent millions 10,2 d'émigrés
clandestins en grande bretagne et que le
patronat anglais utilisent cette main
d'oeuvre et la manche à ce train là va
devenir un cimetière comme la
méditerranée les déjà je rappelle que
trente mille personnes ont péri ou
disparu en mer méditerranée depuis le
début des années 2000 en tentant cette
traversée c'est déjà un cimetière
et c'est vrai que on parle 27
27 un papillon de l'union européenne
c'est dire
d'être aussi la faiblesse de notre
capacité d'accueil aussi de ces gens
là manche effectivement ne doit pas être
un cimetière nous avons une réflexion
commune à mener et à l'issue de cette
réflexion je pense qu'un certain wad
annonces seront faites et vous
comprendrez bien sûr elle cette
l'instant il est prématuré pour moi pour
dire davantage nous allons d'une part
maintenir évidemment cette présence
maximale demandé une mobilisation
supplémentaire des britanniques car je
rappelle qu'en c'était à cet égard nous
nous tenons en quelque sorte la
frontière pour les britanniques et que
toutes ces femmes ces hommes ne veulent
pas l'asile en france de toute façon on
renverra pas tous ces gens là restent
dans ça veut dire quoi monsieur cochrane
l'affairé jean-luc mélenchon par
danville et du président de la
république qu'il ouvre les frontières il
accueille tous les réfugiés il faut être
il faut il faut arrêter vos cammas est
politiquement plus design et à des
limites on accueille de manière digne
ces gens je ne vous annoncerai ni
confinement ni couvre feu dit fermeture
anticipée des commerces ni limitation
des déplacements qui m'a frappé c'est
effectivement une similitude
dans les récits par exemple
c'est des choses qui arrivent
quand elle nous les raconte en fait de
manière très soudaine désormais le
rappel vaccinal sera ouvert à compter de
ce samedi à tous les adultes âgés donc
de 18 ans et plus des cinq mois après
leur dernière injection un moment ça
dérape et ça dérape très rapidement très
brusquement donc s'il fera pas en fait
ces femmes ne se connaissent pas ne se
sont jamais rencontrés et elle nous
raconte des choses qui sont vraiment
très similaires nous réduisons à 24
heures la durée de validité de ces tests
pcr et antigénique qui donne accès au
passé ni terre pour celles et ceux qui
parmi vous n'êtes pas encore vaccinés
donner aussi la parole à des victimes
d'effets secondaires comme le font
d'autres enlevaient d'ailleurs inquiétez
pas le jeune de 16 à tous et s'il ya
parmi des jeunes dit dans les minutes
qui ont suivi votre intervention et
celle de jean michel blanquer reçues
midi des centaines de milliers de
personnes ont tenté de prendre
rendez-vous des millions des personnes
actuellement qui développe des
creutzfeldt jakob florian et d'autres
maladies il faut aussi les entend plus
rien
la parole je souhaite maintenant que ça
se termine